foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Big Mike Westwood one NFL analyst and
joining us on behalf of DraftKings a
sports podcaster he will be on the call
in the booth Cowboys Niners Westwood One
Sunday kickoff at 6 30 Eastern
good to see you Mike
um the the thing we're overrating about
this game and the thing we're
underrating about this game
well I I think what we're possibly
overrating here well I don't know if if
it's overrating to say what Christy
McCaffrey is doing but we might be
overrating saying that
though I think San Francisco is the
better team
um there's a lot of people that think
this this is a team that's going to the
Super Bowl but Dallas played so well
last week that but inconsistently
throughout the year I actually did the
first game a couple of their games the
first game against Tampa Bay in week one
which was a horrible game so I I
actually think that it's possible that
San Francisco could be overrated because
winning 11 in a row and Dallas can be a
little underrated even though they
played very well last week so I probably
lean there the guy that's been and he's
finally getting his Doom we all said
this at the beginning of the Season let
Pollard run the ball yeah I mean he's
got to be the guy over Zeke but Zeke had
been the man for so long it was almost
like you wanted to tiptoe into that and
walk on eggshells when it was like this
guy has a proven better home run hitter
than Zeke he had a better year than Zeke
Zig had all lows in career lows in
rushing yards so I think from an
individual standpoint Pollard has been
the underrated one because I think
people are are afraid to step on the
toes of Zeke Elliott when this is this
is a meritocracy man you get the job
done you get the job and Paula deserves
more time on the field but I wonder if
this has to do with Jerry Jones giving
Zeke Elliott that contract extension and
I at the time said why do I want to get
a running back like that five more years
like I got five I'll move on and Pollard
was the better running back and has been
that home run hitter so I don't know if
that was ego that Jerry's like no he's
got to play because I don't want to look
like I just you know wasted money
Jerry Jones an ego no never that would
not that would never happen dad I mean
come on seriously of course it was I
mean we were all wondering why he was
giving everybody in the world a deal
instead of Dak Prescott and ends up
having to give him Dak a deal after deck
gets hurt sure it was every every owner
GM has an eagle we're going to find out
what goes on in San Francisco down the
road with Trey Lance you know John Lynch
has a GM he's a great player but now
he's a GM he doesn't want to be wrong on
the fact that they traded up to the
number three spot for Trey Lance they
tried to force him in this year you know
and push Garoppolo aside and let's be
honest San Francisco is where they are
because Jimmy Garoppolo needed shoulder
surgery if he didn't need shoulder
surgery he would have been traded away
he'd have been gone and Brock Purdy
would have had to take over early in the
season we have no idea if he would have
played that well early on so yeah going
back to Dallas and Zeke yes it was an
ego of Jerry Jones but Pollard has
proven right now he is the better back
in the backfield we had Albert Breer the
Monday Morning Quarterback on last hour
and he brought up something that I had
not heard about Brock Purdy because it's
it's a small sample size but I said you
know you get a feeling that you know who
Brock Purdy's he said he talked to a
scout who said Brock Purdy had to be the
best player on the field every single
weekend at Iowa State if they had a
chance to win so it's not like he went
in and went hey I got an offense around
me I have to be great every single
weekend and I think that philosophy is
he's not a game manager he wants to make
plays he's used to making big plays so I
I called a couple of his games at Iowa
State where he set those 32 school
records so obviously when you're doing
the games you get a chance to sit down
and talk with these guys and he's
extremely competitive now a lot of guys
in the sport are competitive I mean I
think that can be an overused word but
to your point and what you're saying you
know you're right you know he doesn't
care who he has out there it's not one
of those oh give me more weapons it's
like I'm gonna make do with the weapons
that I have uh and he continued from
that again it would have been
interesting and I'm sure they're glad it
didn't happen if if Garoppolo was gone
and Purdy did have to take over early on
in the season if there would have been
this much success but he's a very
confident guy and confidence is great
but you still have to go execute on the
field he's also it's kind of a it's kind
of a a balancing act Dan because you got
to give Brock Purdy all the credit in
the world but while we're throwing roses
let's also understand that the three
touchdowns his wide receivers had at
least a five-yard cushion he was
throwing the wide open receivers now
again that was in a playoff game and
he's thrown well throughout so before
people sit there and say oh golic's
trashing this guy he has done a great
job but you got to give Kyle Shanahan
credit and how about Brian Griese who's
taking over as the quarterback coach
there as well and the fact that you know
this Dan when we were teammates at ESPN
I mean the trade deadline in the NFL was
just a date nobody did anything now
Christy McCaffrey and TJ Hawkinson have
shown man you can really make some hay
at the trade deadline so you got you
have uh McCaffrey you have Elijah
Mitchell you have Debo Samuel you have
Brandon ayuku who has a career here and
George Kittle so you now have a
pre-snapped read for Brock Purdue who's
a smart quarterback to at least go okay
I got a couple spots I can go here
because I have monster mismatches on the
field because of all this Talent that's
on the field so so it is working hand in
hand with the weapons that he has with
the play caller and Shanahan he has with
the quarterback coach he has and with
Brock Purdy himself who has really
really grabbed a hold of this situation
he's Mike Golic he'll be in the booth
for the Cowboys and the 49ers Westwood
One radio Sunday kickoff at 6 30 Eastern
how much of the pregame will you focus
on Brett Maher kicking
field goals or extra points well you
have to listen I go down in the field
before every game to talk to players and
coaches and the kickers are the first
ones out on the field so you kind of get
their range you know it certainly can be
windy in San Francisco to see where the
other ranges on both sides but let me
tell you a kicker's got to be like
golfers I mean what a what a mental side
this has to be uh in this game and the
Miss and then miss and then miss and
then miss again you know I'm not one
that says I feel bad for players we're
all on the field we all are trying to
make plays and we all get embarrassed at
times it's like I feel bad for the
family probably more than the player but
you got to put him back out there I know
they had another kicker in practice and
they were going over and Brett made five
of five and this other guy made three of
five Brett's gonna be the kicker and you
know what you you in the beginning
especially you have to put them out
there you have to say if you're going to
have him on the active roster in the
beginning of the game you have to have
the confidence to send him out there and
make the kick so if he goes out there
and doesn't make him again then you
rethink a fourth and three or a fourth
and four
I mentioned this in the first hour of
the show how many great quarterbacks are
there in the NFL like truly great
because I don't think the list is as
long as people think I would go
you know you got Patrick Mahomes yeah
Rogers and Brady are Emeritus but
they're not great quarterbacks anymore
right I got Joe burrow who is great yes
I got Josh Allen who's great
after that
who's great well I think Justin Herbert
wants to jump into that category I I
think you look what we have in the AFC
side of the playoffs and these young
quarterbacks wow the future of that
going forward I think he's the next one
that could bust into that category but I
I agree more with you than others who
say there are eight to ten I don't think
there are truly great because you're
juggling you're right the Aaron Rodgers
and Tom Brady of how can you not say
they're great but they're not playing
their best right now they're they're
just that Tom did last year played great
but this year did not so I'm with you on
the smaller amount I would say that
Justin Herbert is the next guy to jump
into that maybe Jalen hurts uh if he's
healthy uh proven he's can be the future
quarterback of that team but but I'm a
big Justin Herbert fan even though I
know a lot of people tear him down a
little bit when they can as they try and
keep continuing to build that team
around them I had somebody compare Dak
Prescott do you want to guess who they
compared Dak Prescott to current
quarterback
I'm horrible at guessing who was it Kirk
Cousins
really see well I mean I I guess I guess
until you get past a certain point
you know in the playoffs and we know
Dallas hasn't gotten past this point
yeah uh in a while and Dak uh is over in
this situation in the divisional round
so you know until you pass a point you
get compared with those that that
haven't passed that point as well while
having good stats so I I get it Kirk
Cousins who I mean all year we've
doubted Minnesota right I mean and but
but this year seemed different because
they were always behind Green Bay and
this year they were in front of Green
Bay but we were always like yeah you
know what can they get it done and we
always point it to Kirk Cousins quite
honestly their defense isn't very good
while Kirk Cousins worked the business
of football better than anybody I get
not having the faith in him and Dak has
to prove for America's team that he can
get past this point to get out of that
comparison so I understand it by how far
you go
give me the surprise this weekend I
don't want to say upset but because I
don't know if Dallas beats the Niners
there are only a four-point underdog or
three and a half now
you got an upset or a surprise well I
actually called last week the Giants
beating Minnesota and as you know it's
all about us being right and not the
game being right it's about how good we
look
um so listen to the Giants can they can
they lose all three to Philly this year
you know we went through that was I
called the Cincinnati Baltimore game
last week they had split during the the
regular season
um I you know I think a lot depends on
Jalen hurts if Jalen hurts does he kick
all the rust off him the Giants are hot
right now I don't I think it's going to
be very difficult for Jacksonville in
Kansas City though I love what
Jacksonville's doing talking to Doug
Peterson a few weeks ago the main word
for him he said with his team is trust
and God knows after last year and that
debacle with Urban Meyer the players
needed to trust somebody but while I was
a former eagle and I loved being an
eagle and I think they're an
unbelievably complete team Jalen hurts
and the injury Jalen hurts and the
possible rust and the way the Giants are
playing they're playing the way you can
win in the playoffs run control hold the
ball and play really good defense Dexter
Lawrence in the middle using his hands
is so much fun to watch I can't believe
he and I played the same position quite
honestly it's unbelievable what he's
doing so while it's it would all Eagle
fans are saying Golic is a former Eagle
how the hell can you say this the Giants
are playing well right now and and the
eagles need Jalen to get back out up to
where he was playing before always great
to talk to you safe travels my best to
the family thank you Mike thanks Dan
good to talk to you that's Mike Golic
Westwood One he'll be in the booth the
Niners and the Cowboys I like that
somebody's you know flipping through the
dial and they're used to hearing Golic
on ESPN they're like wait what
good to have him back